COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY, HAS
BEGUN. WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR A
ROLL CALL. BUT PRIOR TO THAT, I
JUST WANT TO MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT. WE ARE HEARING ONE
BILL ON A 2910 MOTION SB 285 BY
SENATOR ALLEN. OUR USUAL TWO
MINUTE LIMIT ON BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL APPLY,
CAN WE CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE?
BOB. HERE. BOB HERE. SATO HERE.
SATO HERE. BRADFORD SKINNER.
WIENER YOU'RE HERE. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
SENATOR ALLEN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BEGIN? THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL. AS SOME
OF YOU MAY RECALL, A FEW YEARS
BACK, I BROUGHT A BILL, SB 483,
TO THIS COMMITTEE THAT SOUGHT TO
RETROACTIVELY APPLY THE SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT ROLLBACK THAT WE HAD
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS BEFORE
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR
MITCHELL. THAT HAS ALLOWED FOR
MANY, MANY MERITORIOUS CASES TO
BE REVIEWED. AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO HAD
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS THAT HAD
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED THEIR
TIME IN PRISON TO HAVE THEM
REEXAMINED. AND MANY, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S SOME WONDERFUL,
HEARTWARMING STORIES THAT HAVE
COME OUT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
GOTTEN OUT OF PRISON AND HAVE
NOW BUILT SUCCESSFUL AND HAPPY,
HEALTHY LIVES. THAT BEING SAID,
THE BILL HAS BEEN ABUSED BY A
FEW CASES OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO
CHANCE OF GETTING OUT OF PRISON.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOLKS WHO
ARE LU█N DEATH PENALTY CASES,
AND, YOU KNOW, WE SAW THAT THOSE
RESENTENCING HEARINGS WERE BOTH
IRRELEVANT TO THE PERSON AT
HAND, TO THE TO THE PERSON WHO'S
KIND OF FUTURE IN PRISON, BUT
ALSO REALLY SCRATCHED AT A LOT
OF, OF WOUNDS FOR VICTIMS. AND
WE'RE, WE'RE LOOKING TO, TO IN A
VERY NARROW WAY, YOU KNOW,
ENSURE THAT THOSE MOST EGREGIOUS
CASES ARE NOT ABLE TO USE OUR
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION TO, TO, TO
HAVE, KIND OF USELESS
RESENTENCING HEARINGS THAT
CREATE A LOT OF HAVOC AND CLOG
THE COURTS, CLOG THE COURTS, AND
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ULTIMATELY ABOUT. AS I SAY, IT'S
BEEN HEAVILY NARROWED, AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE COMMITTEE ON, ON THE
ANALYSIS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE, DO WE HAVE TWO
OPPOSITION LEAD WITNESSES?
SEEING NONE. DO WE HAVE ANY
METOOS IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. COMMITTEE MEMBERS? DO
YOU GUYS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? SEEING
NONE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFICIENCY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SKINNER TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
YES. AND IT IS RECOMMENDED TO
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS, BE
CONCURRED IN SB 285. CHAIR WILL
HARB. AYE. SATO. SATO. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. WIENER.
WIENER. AYE SO THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. MEETING
ADJOURNED. TOMORROW.